Hey, Lee, good morning.
Hi, Sergi, how are you today?
Doing great. Good morning, Karine. Good to see you.
Good morning. Good.
Karine.
How are you doing?
Long time no see.
I'm good.
Yeah, I know. Yeah, it was two or three weeks ago, I think. Good, good. I'm good.
Yeah, how have you been?
It.
Good, very glad to hear.
Hey, Mike.
Hey, good morning.
Mike, how are you today?
Good morning.
I'm doing good. How are you doing, Lee?
Doing well, thank you.
Oh.
That's good.
Hey, Gaurav.
Good morning, everyone.
Hey, Cooper Top.
Good morning.
Let me think, just love me.
Yeah, I know I spoke with Keith a minute ago. I know he intended to be on. I think he stepped away to get water really quickly, but.
The.
We have got Keith here.
Hey, everyone.
There was Arkadi.
Hey, Keith.
And Ashish.
Yeah, I just tagged him.
Thank you.
Here we have Ashish joining us too.
Morning, everyone.
Good morning.
London.
Hi, Gaurav, how are you?
Morning, she shouldn't be able to wait.
Hello, Mike. Hi, Karine.
Haight.
Is Jessel and Mayur on the journey?
Yeah, we're just waiting for Jessel. I just think.
Yeah.
All right.
Jessel, I see that he declined the meeting.
Let me confirm with you, so...
Kip.
No, he's in today. Let me confirm.
Hoh.
Thank you.
Apparently, I found out what's happened with the co-pilot role. Kris told me that somebody reached out to him, CC Javid, to book a meeting about this role, but the role was never approved and it was not happening because Kris just told me that he was
Drop your email to cancel the search.
Just to just to make sure, but every day it's aware, if it's not true me, it doesn't exist at all. OK, because you are starting the search for nothing, and I hate you to lose time. We have to focus on the open role and just to make sure that it's never happening again. If it's not true me, it's not exist.
Hundred percent.
Got agree.
Engineering.
Absolutely, Karine. Thank you for that. I was on with Tyson yesterday. He reinforced that as well. In fact, he had been talking with us about various rules, and he said, just to be clear, I'm not opening these rules right now. Karine will let you know. And I said, absolutely. We were all in agreement on that side.
Okay.
I.
Yes.
No problem.
I understand how it came about. I was on part of the call, but not the whole of the call. If I had seen the communication, I would have flagged it too, but we'll make sure we're continually calling that eventually when we see it and we'll avoid it. I'll go back to the team now and make sure they clear it from the open orders so we can focus on the...
Mhm.
Okay, perfect.
actual existing list until this becomes a thing.
Yes. Okay, thank you very much. I hate to be the cop, but it's easier and faster like that.
No, no, no, always call them. Always call it out. You can call it out to Sarah, you can call it out to me, you can call it out to any one of us. We'll make sure that it gets fixed. Ideally, we don't hit too many snags where that happens again. I'll go tell the team now, actually, now that we're talking about it again.
But.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Good, thank you.
Thank you, Karine.
Good morning, Jessel. Good morning, Mayor.
Morning, folks. How are you all doing?
We are good, how are you?
OK.
Great.
So, yeah, thank you so much, Jessel, for replying to my email regarding the engineer swap. So, we will ensure that both engineers are available on the time that he had proposed before.
OK, I can go ahead and reach out to, can I go ahead and reach out to Nitin, or did you start that conversation with him as yet?
So, okay, I guess the engineers in question, they are Karthik and Mansh.
I'm not sure if it's Nitin. Nitin isn't getting so upright.
Does not listen.
Nope.
Oh, okay.
So, so question then.
Yep.
He will, well, he's new. He will be new to our team. We would need somebody to cover that.
Last Shift.
How to get him up to speed, yeah?
Yep.
So, this is so we can have an existing engineering report to cover Karthik's shift until this new engineer work in the prime shift to get hands on and complete the required trainings. We can we can do that.
Okay.
I just want to take a quick peek at the schedule. Do you want time to figure it out or you want to discuss it now?
We can discuss it if you're okay with this.
Yeah, yeah. Let's see, who do we have? Who do we have?
I guess Khurana is the only one who's close, closest in that.
That, that um shift, right?
Yep.
As well.
Yeah.
Yeah, Khurana is the other one who is closest in that shift if we if we are able to move him.
To cover that time.
That would be awesome.
Okay.
No, no, no, Khurana is our current star, prime time wise.
He, he does it.
Yeah, since Karine is more tenured, so he should be able to take care of this change also.
Yeah.
He gets very good customer feedback and reviews, by the way.
Yep, thank you so much, Jessel. So, Karan will cover Karthik's shift starting July 2nd, I presume.
Yeah.
Yes.
Okay.
All right, and obviously Karthik's new shift would be 8 Eastern, as the shift that is being done by one Sean Reza Sport, and once one shift timing's gonna be, is it 8 A.m. Eastern, or do you want him to do?
Gardens shipped.
Current, current shift.
Well, the first the first week or so, he's gonna be in orientation, so it is it.
Mhm.
Eight Eastern.
Eight Eastern is our our six six.
Is our six?
CST.
Yeah, that's not bad. That's not bad for him to be in that time slot to begin with.
Is that something that we could shift later on or?
Yes, I think that is something that we can obviously cover, the basis of the requirements and needs, so that's not a problem.
Okay.
Okay, so is it a current shift or is it the regular ADMIN shift for?
Lunch.
Yeah, if he could, if he could slip in the current shift, then that would be ideal, actually.
Okay.
Yeah, but you could always give me feedback and let me know if it is that we need to use somebody else and shift their own and that doesn't work for them, right?
I know, I know Karine has newborn baby and stuff as well.
Absolutely.
Okay.
Yeah.
Any other questions around this?
Is it?
I can go ahead and send a meeting request to the bunch. Is he aware?
Yeah, when she's aware of this.
Okay. Okay, no problem. Okay.
Sure.
Right.
Sure, thank you very much.
You're welcome. Second thing that I wanted to discuss is regarding the 24 by 7 coverage. I had to connect with Mayor yesterday. Mayor, I hope you are welcome.
Yes, I am. Good morning, everyone.
Thank you. So, we discussed about, you know, having one of the engineers to be available for this new schedule to cover the 24 by 7. So, do we have the shift timings available now? Like, what would be the proposed shift timings for the new individuals?
Ashish, not yet. That's something, again, we are working on, like how many shifts and exact timings. And we want to have some overlay as well between the changing hands. So yeah, that's exactly what we're working on at the moment, on identifying exact time.
Um, and and and on that, but uh, as soon as I have anything solid on that, I'll just send you a message.
Appreciate it. Thank you.
Okay.
So, since we have the full house on the call, I got to know that Gaurav was appointed as a new technical team lead for Helpdesk team. So, congratulations, Gaurav.
Thanks, thanks, everyone.
I hope you're lacking the team you're working with, and what's your experience overall till date?
The whole team is really good. Everyone is doing their part really well. Everybody's listening to, adhering to the SLA policies from the speak work. There have been a few challenges, but I've had one-to-one with some technicians and they've got it resolved, so we hope like we can.
Build a better team going out.
Yep, yeah, I got to know. I guess some of the engineers they were required to fill in, resubmit the time sheets because they were not, they did not have to complete 9 hours in those time entries, so...
Yeah, so there were challenges with the time sheets and I rejected them twice, but I've done one-to-one with with most of them as to tell them how to actually do the time sheets and then and then they're completely well, so it's all good.
Mm.
Thank you.
Okay, Jessel, over to you. Please let us know how were the last two weeks with the team, the engineers, and what's your feedback?
Um...
I think I would have made, you know, wanting notes along the way, but a general comment and feedback that I got from a few people that I didn't get to address one on one as yet with the team. And this is, you know, a few tier ones, of course, that the research in the IT glue.
and actually digging and finding information might be a little tough at times, but I feel like based on the feedback, we aren't getting people even searching and doing basic searches to find the information. So they're poking and nudging their colleagues.
to find it for them. And that in itself, you know, creates a lot of additional work technically for somebody else and puts a bit of a strain. So I kind of want to go through one on one. I did it in our last huddle. I did cover it quickly, but I'm going to go through it one on one with people and start doing that.
in order for them to be able to find information themselves, because it's super important that they're digging, looking through, reading a lot of information in IT Glue. And that also, because we have a lot of nuances with customers where there's approvals.
and how users are set up, etc. It's super important that they look at the documentation for that customer and do what's necessary. And I think that's what we're missing a lot of these times. And I want to be, you know, a bit tight on it.
I think that's a general feedback that I have for the team so far. But other than that, I think on a positive note, the customer CSAT scores are trending positively. There's a lot of good interaction from techs, you know, whatever customer service training that you all have.
It is, it is doing well. Yeah, we do see positive results from it so far, so thanks for that.
Mm.
Thank you. And since Adriel and Sandeep, they have just recently started, Sandeep has completed his training, so he now worked on the tickets. And Adriel started working on the tickets from the past week. So we do have some information in terms of his billable and the tickets he closed.
Just wanted to know how he's doing since he is pretty new to the environment and Sandhu being a level 2 engineer. So I would like to check same with Mike. How is he doing and if there are any areas of opportunity with him.
Yeah, good question. Yeah, Mike and Cooper Tap are going to have to give you the details. I haven't been involved with them as much. Ajay and Sandhu Deepak, so whichever Mike or Cooper Tap, whichever one they all want to go first.
Sure, I'll start. So, Ajay, I've had a few interactions with him. I've had one-to-one with him yesterday as well, and I feel like he's getting a hold of the policies here at MSB4. He's doing good. There was an issue with the timesheet submissions with him as well.
So.
It was two time sheets that were not submitted. So as he's new, so it's totally understandable. Like he didn't know how to do that. So I just showed him and then he submitted them timely.
That's pretty much it because it's pretty new, so I don't have a lot of information about him, but then yeah, he's doing that so far.
Thank you.
As for Sandeep, I would say he's doing very good as well. Got him on a couple of tickets already since his training. I haven't noticed any major concerns. He seems very eager to pick things up, learn and encounter challenges, which is really nice. And one other thing I've noticed is he
Like.
likes to communicate a lot with the team, whether it be like tier twos or tier ones. He really likes to learn both workflows. And I see that as a huge asset. The more relationships that he can build with the tier ones, the easier it'll be for them to escalate to him.
All right.
Thank you so much, Mike, for sharing that. All right, so now I will switch to Mayur's team. So, Mayur, how were the last two weeks with the engineers?
Yeah, overall, all good. Just one focus, I just need to reiterate to the team, all three of them, is the incoming calls. So one of their four responsibilities is triaging the incoming calls. Lately, I have noticed that that's something is going out of focus.
for, I would say, from now for like, and then this is just I noticed in the last two weeks. I'm yet to connect with them to understand what's going on, but just, yeah, just an observation so far in the last two weeks. But otherwise, I would say, as...
We have reduced overall load on the team as well, that I expect that answering calls now should be like more frequent now. I'm still waiting on Luware and on the data and metrics and on that, so until I have that.
The only thing I rely on at the moment is just seeing that, you know, the Teams call queue ringing and I can see who has answered that because I'm part of the same queue. So, and I see most of the time who jumps on the call if the call went to voicemail and all that. So just want to be, that's exactly what I noticed in the last two weeks. So.
Yes, that's it, I guess. Otherwise, they are working fine, adding notes and times and everything in the right manner, so I think we did.
Great. Thank you, Manu, for sharing the feedback. I just have a quick question. I believe just like PSL's pod, the report is also following the round-robin method of getting the incoming calls. Is it whosoever is available in the queue gets the call?
No, right now, whoever is available right now. So, and usually we rely heavily on L1s because L2s are more on site and on that. So right now is whoever is available in the queue, they would pick up the call.
S.
What is it? Is it broadcast or is it round robin?
Alright.
Yeah, is it broadcast? Yeah, it is broadcast at the moment.
Okay.
Hayre.
Right.
time and that actually significantly improved things in general as well.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's what I'm reviewing with Luware, but it's just, it's moving really slow on our end. So, but yeah, that's exactly what I'm investigating for the, like, once we implement Luware, that's the change we are going to bring with that.
I.
Oh, you, I thought you went on to Laroia.
No, it's moving really slow on our end, so yeah.
If you can.
With, yeah, with the challenges in the projects team, so yeah, that's affecting our internal projects as well.
If you're working with David Peebles on it for the team for the teams calling, we recently also did shifts in in Teams, and he he routes the calls based on shifts, so that's also an option, right?
Yes.
Yeah.
Alright, OK. We have, we we used shifts here already, like in our London office, so yeah, definitely it's good, good connection to make for sure.
Hoh.
Yeah, so until a loop error is implemented, Mayor, I guess it's numbers that we are using to calculate the calls incoming and how they are being answered.
So, it's a, I guess it's a same product like Luware Nimbus or Nimbus Luware. Again, I'm not sure like what what is the brand name and then what's the product name. So, both are the same product. Currently, for London and Gulf offices, we are just relying on the on the standard Teams phone system.
I.
Okay.
Right.
Thank you.
Any other points, Manu, you wanna share?
No, that's pretty much it. And just wanted to check, have you discussed with Safaraj like on just availability outside the regular hours?
I have not discussed it yet. I was actually thinking that we would have shift timings on this call, so I would have a substantial information with me to make the discussion. But if you want me, I can have a discussion with Sarah so that we have, you know, at least a picture around it, that this is what we are planning and so he would have things in his mind.
Okay, okay, makes sense.
Right.
Yeah, no, I would say just give him a heads up and as soon as I have the timings available, I'll, yeah, I'll reach out to you and we can discuss it.
Thank you so much.
All right, before I jump into presentation at deck, I forgot to introduce. We have Keith Rozario with us on the service call. Sorry, Keith. You know, it all started so that, you know, I completely forgot to introduce you. My bad. So, Keith is working with IT by design as a senior technical team lead.
No worries, no worries.
So he will be a part of the service calls along with me to support us so that services are delivered in the expected manner and we both can collectively work if there are any issues or concerns.
Yeah.
Nice. Thank you. Thank you, Ashish. Looking forward to work with you guys. Thank you.
Yes.
I think Keith.
Thank you.
All right.
With that being said, I'll quickly go ahead and share my screen.
I hope it's visible.
Yes, yes.
Thank you. So this is the utilization data for the team starting June 1st till June 12th. I have categorized data engineer-wise. So I'll give you a minute so that you can just go through the numbers and then if you have any questions, you can let me know.
The screen is visible, Ashish.
Visible, yeah.
Kip.
So previously, when we spoke, it was Nitin's utilization that was in question. He was in late 60s, so he was able to pick up the billable numbers. It is now 71% on an average for June 8th till 12th, and his numbers are better.
for the last week too. For Stephen, we see a dip from 71 to 67. He is also ensuring that his billable stays above 70% and this will be fixed. So that's all I concern. And
For Karthik, he's also about to touch 70 here, since we have him getting swamped with the other engineer. So we would have a new engineer bunch, and probably he would also match what Karthik was delivering in terms of the numbers.
Surpass the expectations what we have as compared to other engineers in the team, Nitin, Rahul, Stephen, and Gaurav.
Yeah, I mean, Karthik is on the tail end, that late shift, where there'd be a lot less calls, so that's why, that's why I think that that's also a factor as well, right?
Yep.
Hoh.
Any other questions just along this slide?
Pre.
No, I'm good, thanks.
Mayur, anything from your side?
I think he's driving, so I can skip.
No.
Kip.
Um...
Mike, we would have Sandeep's numbers from the next Connect because his training was just completed. So we will ask him to start sharing his utilization data and we'll start populating it here in our upcoming Connects.
That sounds good. Thank you.
Welcome.
Okay, this is the performance overview of the team. So overall, the utilization is trending with specific mentions of billable contributions. With resource management, we have Karthik will be swapped with Vansh from Reza Sport. Sandeep and Ajay, they have completed their trainings and they are gradually climbing up.
the ticket numbers. We have ensured that team is available for the coverage for July 1st. We have team on off. And yeah, so team would be on off and they would be working as usual from July 2nd. In terms of ticket hygiene,
the work role selection, Jessel, that you had mentioned previously. We have ensured that no patching ticket is going under workload selection of L1. So this is being taken care during my board reviews. Just wanted to know, you have also observed the same value to the board reviews of the engineers.
Yes.
Wait.
Thank you. Calls answered. We have ensured that team is available and proactive in terms of answering the calls. The instance that was shared last week, Jessel, so it was Ronald and Stephen, they were on the call at the same time because of which that the customer call was missed. However, I have approached the engineers to ensure
that we should have at least, you know, someone to take care of the calls if they are going on a call to work on an issue together.
Okay, thank you.
Right, and yeah, as far as leaves are concerned, so we don't have any planned leave for the month of July yet. I will reach out to Team once again if they have any any planned leave for July, I will share it in email.
The.
Oh, they did they didn't apply, they're not getting it.
Yeah, right. And thank you so much, Jessel, for being... I'm sorry.
I'm kidding. I know, I know they have, yeah, they have kind of the day off, right?
Yes, so.
Okay, so after July 1st, right, that day will be off. Okay, so.
Yep, yep.
Okay, awesome.
But still, if you want them to be available for the coverage, there might be some clients who would be calling in for support. If you feel like it would happen, do let us know and I can make sure that Team is available for the coverage.
Sure.
Uh, Manu, that was for you as well. It was not just for just...
Yes, yeah. Thank you.
I.
Welcome.
Okay, let me just quickly and share my screen.
Right, this is all I have in terms of the data presentation. Any other questions, Jessel, you have?
All good to know.
No.
I'm good.
Thank you, Gaurav.
Good as well. I'm all good. Thank you.
Blake.
Not good.
Yeah, thank you all so much for being supportive and responsive in general. I think this is a, you know, good function that we have going here. Ashish in particular is always very responsive. So thanks for that. That's really good.
I appreciate it, Jessel. Thank you so much. And you have been proactive with the communications that we have. So yeah, kudos to you and the team. Thank you.
Thank you, everyone.
Bye.
Thank you, Team.
Thanks, everyone. Bye.